so Mario puffs rabbits kindom battle is
the game we just announced we're super
happy we were announcing the game
yesterday at the conference and since
then we start to show a bit of the
gameplay yep so we're super happy to
show today more of the basics and combat
basics exploration and so that's what
we're gonna do and in terms of the game
itself so what happened is the rabbits
have just been teleporting to the
kingdom a twisted version of the
Mushroom Kingdom
yeah and it changed completely the
Kingdom in itself by twisted 8 so you'll
have a lot of surprises and elements in
the environment but basically Mario
doesn't know anything about the rabbits
when the game starts so we're still at
the beginning of the game here but
basically that's when things start to go
a bit crazy with crystal elements even
have this plan here there's a bit
special so yes we tried to recreate a
very in massive water by using the mist
proportion so you feel that you are
small in a huge environment which is
enveloping you and everything around you
is animated alight for example this
plant it's incredible because it's
animated by hand and it's following the
music of grant kirkhope which is their
composer of the game so it's one of the
things that are I love about this game
it's part of things that mr. Miyamoto
Nintendo and us as well Ubisoft wanted
to see as well the terms of detail
things that we wanted to play with so
yeah let's go and a big part of the game
as well as the combat itself and when
the player see those enemy flags in
front of them they know that they are
about to play right
five grand before we go in actually
there is a couple interesting characters
following Mario let's talk about them a
little bit yeah so aside the big Goomba
there's been almost played with because
of the rabbits and stuff for the
characters and heroes himself so we have
Mario of course he's a true hero he's a
fighter like character in combat as well
so he's really strong almost everywhere
but he also have a rabid Peach
she's a hot-tempered quite fun of Mario
but hot-tempered rabbit and a very
strong personality as well and rabbit
Luigi third one he's wizard like type of
character uh he's really clumsy naive
but at the same time he's quite
dangerous in combat and as a game
progresses as well so yeah it's a it's a
nice cast and this gas is the baton cast
so as you progress into the game you'll
unlock new heroes so you don't unlock
the heroes at the beginning you lock
them throughout the adventure now can we
say what other characters there will be
in the game as well
sure solutely so player will control
eight the other week we could we'd be
able to choose between eight years at
the end so that would be the players
roster and we really wanted to play
along this contrast between Mario
character and the rabbit swan-like in
order to create the you more so if there
is something that their habits learn a
mile throughout the game is how to
become heroes and modular how to cut the
joke
so we don't fight yeah let's do it yeah
definitely
so you switch from exploration mode to
battle mode this way so basically when
you see those two flags you switch to
battle mode and you don't control
anymore directly your characters you
control beep Oh little cursor you see in
front and this little guy in fact is
telling you you can tell him where to go
and the characters will follow so that's
a big difference between the two at
first it was a good match you know
between exploration combat in terms of
the feeling we have
so so as you started the comet that
flycam is showing you the battle gong
but you can always use the tactic camp
which is a tool that will let the player
observe the surrounding to decide what
to do the best move take and as you can
see in the top right part of the string
the mission objective it's a rich area
so it's not really important to defeat
the enemy there but to really decide the
best way possible way to our eye
directly at the objective so the player
will have two choices directly in front
of the enemy that seems a little bit
risky or moving a little bit on the
right to use the cover and being
protected by the TAC of the rabbits so
what you see right now is survey which
is controlling the ears in this case we
each arrows can perform three different
type of action as we are quite early in
the game right now we have only movement
and attack later on there will be
techniques which is way more let's say a
ninety eight way to deal with an enemy
and it's more magical but the the blue
line is defining where the characters
can move and in this case it's a vehicle
for example go behind the cover in order
to be alpha tattered or just go in front
of them so as soon as you press the
character moves and like David a said we
can attack but it will show first the
movement phase itself you can do
whatever you want you can move first
attack then it's up to you to decide in
fact you cannot pass towards another
color such for example as
this region is doing or even better you
can move the cursor behind one of your
teammate in order to activate what we
call the pin jump the team jump is
expanding your area of movement allowing
you to go much further than your normal
area of movement right and this is also
allowing you to fill the gaps such as
the small river that you can see in
front of you
after that you you can choose but there
is no sequence like exactly so basically
here we just finish the movement phase
and now we can see in this fight that
the enemies are positioned in a way to
Zerg you they called Ziggy's those guys
are don't have a lot of Life Points but
there are really - you all the time so
it's good that I'm on the other side
with Mario thanks to the team jump so
when you're ready you press a new attack
and what you may have seen just over the
the enemy is the percentage hit
percentage so 100% means 1% chance to
hit if they are behind a half cover full
cover it changes so we'll see that just
later on so I'll continue with the the
attack here and even defeat the enemy in
the process
he's a zapped out and in terms of story
basically they're not dying they were
going back to the hub as white rabbits
so we're actually saving the rabbits
that's great you feel good about the gap
that still hope fine because builds I
don't want to spoil too much about the
story but they have being controlled by
a fox and by defeating them you are
removing this fast from them
they are part of the gameplay loop loop
of the players because they will go back
to the pitch castle and the more you
freedom the more they will build the
structure that will add the player
throughout their adventure
so we saw their mario was attacked but
he's behind a full cover so the enemy
had 0% chance of hitting him but the
cover did take damage I know this
exactly so we it's actually something
really important the combat itself they
are actually a side one that we have
later in the game
no coverage it is really instant like
they have this amount of damage and if
they get destroyed you don't have any
cover anymore to defend yourself so for
example here if I go and attack this
enemy I know I'm gonna have to hit it
it's 0% chance but just to show you the
the damage on the cover itself this is a
wood cover so in two hits is going to be
destroyed and the one you see here next
to rabbit luigi is a brick cover so this
one is a bit more tough so we hit so
basically that's really important in the
game itself to use this the enemies will
do it you will do it so and this is cool
because you can also use interactive
element in the battleground such as the
rabbits pipe the rabbit pipe really
helps you to go in other places where
you couldn't reach just with your aerial
moment so when you use a tactic em spot
those pipes and you know use a
trespasser experience so that's why the
observation path is important and we
gave this to to the players in order to
really study if they want to the basket
on
definitely it does count for you you do
have to explore a bit to really figure
out that turn-based strategy and find
out what the best advantages you have
especially in this new level and
environment that you're encountering
exactly here you know it's even we
showed some gameplay yesterday of the
conference it was a justified after this
one is before like the video was saying
we don't even have the techniques but
one thing here that is really important
for us in terms of design and philosophy
was you see the water
this is creating your gap so it teaches
you to use team jump a lot but the
enemies do not use team jump those guys
are dashers you don't have Globetrotter
go towards the second or archetype we
have they do team jumps but here we
really want to show the player like hey
you can protect yourself then we'll -
you eventually because they will take
the pipe by the end of the map trying to
rush you but it depends because
according where you are in the fight
we'd never know what the enemies can do
but they should do that in this map
because again this we want to teach you
this is the way you can play as well you
can reach you know bigger zones and
reach new areas but also you can go over
gaps like water and this is quite cool
and later in the game you don't even
have light so if you go up there you
have an advantage in terms of damage so
it starts to build up you know we start
to put the ingredients together and this
map is three minutes into the game so
it's really a good map to start to
interpret oh yeah they are still
learning yeah so it's really up to them
where to move they want to go directly
against the enemy and risking to be
dashed but they maybe could arrive at
the objective sooner or they want to
take wait maybe a more safer route like
the one we are taking right now because
we are moving helping each other using
the protection of the color right and
you had mentioned that the objective for
this battle is really to get to this
final checkpoint yeah there are
different different battles where you
actually have to defeat all the enemies
so here it's a tricky map of course
we're playing we know for
watch the map but first player is going
to be a first tricky map because they
could think this as oh we like to defeat
all the enemies but the issue is that we
have a lot of every spawn and the more
you wait the more more enemies will
spawn and it's going to be very
complicated so here it's a reach
objective you need to reach running
character needs to be in the zone and
this is something key for the players to
do and then we have multiple enemy
objectives we have defeat defeat all
defeat this type of enemy reach escort
and those type of objectives throughout
the game to really challenge the player
again to do the right decision when it
matters
so rabbit luigi is really close now he's
not close enough because we might have
got enough to arrive on objective
definite is something that you that
we've never seen before really with
Mario and he's pairing up with this
matchup but also you know we have a you
know Mario the first I'm really using a
weapon a projectile weapon yeah yeah you
know Mario has never been afraid to take
whatever power-ups are you know
available to him so it's cool to see
these new types of weapons that he can
play with he's adapting to a surrounding
right yes plus they are very very light
after than funny because the weapons in
our game are not just there in order to
the major dynamics but they are also a
tool to create fun because you can plug
additional behavior such as you can glue
an enemy on the ground there is a a
particular particular enemy that is very
powerful using the techniques you can
freed this face so he cannot speak
anymore therefore he can do that use the
techniques there is someone very good at
shooting you can hink his face or he
cannot see you and you cannot shoot at
you you can burn enemies so they are
running with their bottom on fire and
there is also propagation so if an enemy
on fire is touching another enemy will
propagate there are some crazy behavior
that could happen within the battlefield
and that's what we call the domino
effect so you can chain multiple
effector and the output would be very
very crazy also when you finish the
fight you can go back first to the zone
in free movement an exploration mode all
the the cleansing you have on your
battlefield is because when you destroy
covers you get rewards as well so even
if you hit an enemy behind a cover and
the cover is destroyed it's rewarding as
well for the player so you can go back
and buy better weapon thanks to coins
but if we have a few minutes we just
wanted to show something as well here
just a quick fact you know we went that
way for the fight itself but in fact the
most effective way would say advanced
way would have been to go that way even
if it's dangerous the first round you
get you know - and stuff second round
you really - getting me well so a good
strategy would be to put Morial on the
right side he's a good damage output
into his weapon jeez not really good
with his weapon but he's good with
dashing so you can put it in front line
and then you go really quickly to the
zone here so yeah we just revealed
something for people when they will play
they know how to play the map now but
yeah it's up to the player to decide
they can go front or go left right
whatever they have in mind they can go
for it depends on the playstyle itself
because a good tactical game should give
the player the choice to choose their
strategy so not only in terms of how you
want to customize your character which
kind of weapon you want them to be
equipped with but also the plan that you
want to take into the battlefield so we
didn't want for the battles to have only
one possible solution but multiple so um
let's go to the pitch castle to show the
hub itself yeah let's take a look we
didn't present it yet although it's a
big part
of the game of course so it's of course
it's a peach castle it was not destroyed
by the arrival of the rabbits so thank
god this is good haha but the issue or
let's say the challenge for peach as a
princess as well is that the castle will
have evolved as the game progresses so
as you progress you'll see more stuff
build by the rabbits of it randomly or
not randomly like this one ballots you
to change your team change your weapons
change your skills in the skill tree
access new world so this one is the
first one ancient gardens anyhow we'll
have many puzzles around that you have
to solve and as you finish a world you
get new contextual actions in
exploration as well so you can progress
and see other places that you can go
before so this is key as well for the
player to you know go back to the hub
and see what they could do now that have
new abilities so yeah this hub will
evolve throughout the game and we won't
be able to show today you know the other
worlds but as soon as you finish your
world you can accept a new one with this
new ability and the cannon takes you and
achieve you in the world itself and we
just saw an example here of a little
puzzle that we we have with the right
points that we have in a game as well so
we have a yellow Kwan's red pawns blue
coins as well in the bug zones museum
where you get all the collectables from
the game you can gather in the game this
one is still broken when you're at that
moment in the game but it's the washing
time machine that's what they use to
come in the world itself of Mario and it
will be useful in the future you can go
back and revisit and get better scores
in all the fights that you've done and
also other elements that here are you
know teasing that the player will
discover new worlds here xrx RL so
that's really an important part of the
game as well this happened how it will
evolve with the game itself and I do
remember that the Appa
one of the first things that we decided
to do we did a game like really a point
of contact for the player to to really
help me throughout the whole game and I
remember when we were told that we are
about to work with intent on a game that
was featuring both Mario and Arab Itza
and we immediately understood that it
was a lifetime opportunity we worked
really night and day in order to find
something unique for their habits butter
as well for Mario so as we are huge
tactical fan we said okay we should use
them to propose something fresh
something new in the turn-based combat
games and but at the same time we wanted
to stay true to the modern universe and
therefore we decided to mix those two
different phases but in a single single
seamless way like the combat and
adventure and at the end when we felt
that we had a solid idea we decided to
meet with Nintendo and I remember that
we had only three weeks and a half it
was crazy to remember to to really
prepare something and when I finally met
mr. Miyamoto I felt like he's the
creator of my favorite game it's the
inspiration of my career as a game
designer and I felt like if I was
divided like in two so the passionate
Nintendo player and they will be so
strategy director the urgency to ask for
an autograph are and the responsibility
to present the game the most
professional way sure but the D and the
effort paid off because I say he told me
that he was impressed and
keep asking how come that we had Varian
region in our prototype but the true is
that even if we spend we had only three
weeks and I have to work in the
prototype we recreated Mario and widget
from scratch the modeled animation
during in order to try to translate
their essence in our prototype and I
guess I think that this is was the
moment where we truly convinced Nintendo
about our commitment and passion so from
that moment on we kept meeting with them
in Kyoto it was a incredible journey and
Mario's habits Kingdom battle become
really a work of a lot a lot of love
that's such a basic story yeah I think
you guys have a lot to be proud of and
and I know that mr. Miyamoto you know
he's hard to impress and you guys have
worked really hard and then super proud
of what you guys have come up with like
I can't wait to play the full game and
it's just beautiful looking at the
graphics of the picu tactical style but
also the exploration of the gaming it's
a do style that we never really entire
before so I didn't sleep a lot last
month in years but we're super happy to
be here and uh and talk about the game
it feels great like you know we were
almost like in the cave you know walking
and working in this game and I think for
the team the ball team left team all the
studios to be here today to talk about
the game show the game finally it's just
uh yeah super exciting
yesterday press conference was uh yeah
went very well and we'll of all the
emotions we had on the it was great and
I think now Turing the game like that
it's uh just incredible thank you
awesome thank you so much for coming so
this was Mario plus rabbit's Kingdom
battle and then up next we have fire
above warriors stay tuned for more